okay this is a 30-second warning uh mr
ripples in the room or do you need some
okay
it being 1002
i'm going to go ahead and convene
the first hearing today on
1677.
this is going to turn out to be
more of an informational slash
working meeting
the committee won't be taking any uh
um
persistent votes on this we may
want to just take a sense of where
everybody's at but that if if we do that
it'll whatever process we use will be
informal
so i guess the gavel makes it official
but
do we have somebody here
from the child us advocacy child usa
organization
two people just stood up three people
so so so i'm going to just
try it one more time is there anyone
here from the child us advocacy or child
usa organization we've received written
testimony and i'd like to extend you an
offer opportunity to speak to your
testimony
okay
seeing no one moving um
let's bring up um the ag and his dynamic
duo
thank you representative edwards and
members of the committee good morning
just for the record john from ella
attorney general
over the past couple weeks since the
last work session we've really made an
effort to have discussions with
stakeholders have discussions with
plaintiff's council
and
the results of those discussions were
the proposed or potential edits that we
submitted earlier this week that i think
to my right uh as before is senior
assistant attorney general now jen
ramsey just as a quick aside i just want
to make everyone aware jen was just
promoted earlier this week to senior
assistant attorney general so that
reflects the
excellent work she's she's doing for the
office so that reflects more than just a
senior moment
yes
okay
so jen has been instrumental in
in leading the effort to put some of
these proposed revisions down on paper
so i'm gonna have her take the lead on
at least initially walking you through
these revisions but we'll both be here
to answer questions she and i have
discussed these extensively so we're
both familiar with them but as the
primary drafter i wanted to give jen the
opportunity to to walk these uh walk you
through these so i will turn it over for
the moment to senior assistant attorney
general jennifer ramsey
thank you miss ramsey and our mr
attorney general and ms ramsey uh we do
we do have the documents in front of us
and so um but i don't think these are
viewable by the uh
public
so just to get it on the record if you
could touch upon each one
but because i'd like to keep this to 30
to 45 minutes if you could just be
judicious about how much time you spend
on each one
obviously if it's a minor thing just let
us know if it's a if it's a major
thought process we would like to
understand that
that sounds great
so for the record jennifer ramsey
and
i think everybody has a document that
says summary of recommendations for
amendment at the top of it
um i would uh like to try to take them
instead of in the order on that document
just to take them instead in the order
that they appear in the in the language
of the bill if that would be helpful
um
i may be the only one but it would be
more helpful
by a factor of eight if we were to go
down your summary document
and and then if we uh
and then just even if we're jumping
around in the document just
because we're also going to be putting
time stamps our
clerk is going to be using your summary
sheet as a way to have our minutes taken
and we're going to
time stamp the meeting instead of taking
document notes
i'm happy to do it that way as well
so
if we start then with the the first item
on the summary is uh one of the things
that we did after input was uh we talked
about this last session we expanded the
right to know coverage to include
settlement agreements not being a part
of the
of the confidentiality of
of the documents of the ydc settlement
fund
we also included in this latest draft of
the bill a typographical error i think
that was also the subject of a previous
amendment and then we on the
recommendation and input of a lot of
members in the victim advocate community
have strengthened the the language in
the statement of purpose
we're no longer reflecting that
abuse may have ac occurred we're we're
reflecting uh that we are investigating
abuse um and we've included a statement
that um that we want to acknowledge that
if i could just ask you to slow down a
little bit because in your 40 seconds
you just went through three things on
three different pages
and i i want people to be able to see
what the change is okay so if you could
pace us through
as we look at your document and look at
the amendment
okay so the language i was just
referring to is on page one it's item
thank you
and you strengthened this the purpose
statement in what way would you would
you just talk to the uh add-on here sure
so you'll see in line two that we remove
the language which may have occurred
and that's uh because of some feed that
back that we received from the the
advocates community that that language
might be offensive to victims
we are referring to this as an
investigation into abuse and we've also
added a statement um acknowledging the
claims and and what the victims have
all right that's clear to me thank you
okay next if we move to language on page
okay explain what we're doing here
yep you'll see that we have created an
affirmative obligation of
confidentiality on the part of the
administrator of the fund um the
claimant is not bound by that and can
speak freely but to the extent that the
claimant which is to have
the information
uh remain private this would create an
obligation on the administrator
to do that
thank you i understand that
if there are questions as we go uh get
my attention
because while the topic is fresh in
everyone's mind we can address it but so
far i think we're all tracking or do you
have something representative earth
i am tracking but i just want to be
clear that the summary recommendations
for amendment no longer has the correct
line number references is that an
accurate statement
if you have a version that was generated
by the um
by the legislative services group i
don't have that version so that may be
the reason for the differences
it does look like they're adding numbers
to me well we would see something just
this morning
that has a number four in a circle next
to it next to line 24 and line 24 begins
g claims on all documents which i think
is what you were just talking about
is that are you looking the same thing
i'm looking at the same language you are
but my document is numbered differently
so who who can you
where is the variation coming from here
representative long
i think
thank you mr chairman that copies you
received are my notes so the the circled
numbers is my notes from these
from the recommendations
and i also wrote my notes in there so
the circled numbers are what i
referenced as the recommendations well
it looks like you reform out of the
document too
so so i i appreciate you letting us use
your document representative long i i've
i've been finding it useful so
um i i think
i think if we can get into the right
neighborhood and so we at least see the
you know the language and we're tracking
with what ms ramsey is saying
we we should not be too worried about
the line numbers at this point because
we're going to
right so i think we're all looking at
that i think so too it's just something
and then and then i asked for pat long's
notes to get xeroxed because he had he
had red and yellows
and it just made it easier to track okay
so i
think i think if we
are trying to understand intent we ought
so so so representative irf plays a
vital role on division three finance of
making sure that all of the debits and
credits are lined up properly so
so are you are you are you okay ready to
roll
okay so is there a question about that
section or just the
no i i think the general question was
just curiosity on off by the
representative on how we should be using
and viewing these documents
my my main concern is that we are able
to understand what the ag's office was
thinking and that we're able to
correlate that to the written word so
and i think you're doing that
thank you so should we move on to number
five mr chairman
representative walsh yeah can i just ask
the ag to slow down just a little uh you
guys are have been working with this
every single day you're intimately aware
of it we're playing catch-up i'm trying
to read this and you're going faster
than we can read and absorb it so just
slow down just a little so we actually
have time to read it before you move on
if you don't mind please i'm happy to do
we're
we're slowly ready when you are okay
um
if we're ready number five um
should be a quick one page three lines
twenty eight to twenty nine
we just changed
the date of the ending of the claim
filing window so it was previously a one
year period and now it's a two-year
uh yes moon representative mooney if you
wouldn't mind um i have a question on
that
okay thank you and thank you for your
presentation your emails i thought the
materials were very clear so thank you
my question on moving that date what are
the pros and the cons of a one year
versus a two year window
or vice versa i find that section
particularly to be very critical
and and
do you have a thinking that one or the
other is is preferable
it would seem to me that in one year it
would be
managed
i guess more reasonably as opposed to
over two years time
perhaps things might get
lost in the shuffle and not be as tight
as they would be in a one-year window
okay thank you thank you for that the
reason that we expanded it was based on
feedback at the last working session
that there were also folks that felt
that one year would be too short of a
time period that um that because this is
a process for people um to be have the
courage to sort of come forward with
these types of allegations that we
needed to give
more time
for people to
come forward and not rush them through
the process but i understand what you're
saying as well
so so let's use this as a teaching point
for a second um
last meeting that you were here
you received a lot of feedback from
representatives and and so
you've gone away you've consulted with
the plaintiff's attorneys where possible
and you've applied your own independent
thought so on this particular point what
i assume happened was it had been one
year you heard that maybe two years is
better regardless of what you heard it
got you thinking and in your independent
judgment you think the two-year
window is superior to a one-year window
i'm assuming that this document doesn't
just represent what we said but this
represents your professional independent
judgment on the right way to go i i
think you've stated it well
that's correct okay thank you and and
there were to add to that there were
people that thought it should be much
longer
and after giving it more consideration
we thought two
item six is uh that we recommended to uh
lift the 100
the 1980 uh date restriction for claims
again we rethought that after feedback
at the last work session
the initial
date recommendation that claims would
not be for incidents occurring prior to
1980 was based on the attorney general's
general sense of the
where the most of the claimant's claims
lie um and we have since been um
persuaded that there may be claims that
uh lie in earlier
dates and then it makes good sense to to
include those claims in the bill as well
so your intent is just to open this up
to anybody anytime
correct with the with the uh language in
the bill still being that administrators
of its estates cannot file claims um so
there will be some as a practical matter
limitation on people that are still
living but other than that anybody who
has a claim of this type that was ever
at the ydc or one of the other
facilities would be entitled to
participate in this process
all right thank you
your mask is fine but if you would turn
on your mic and speak directly into the
mic
we we have people out there like
representative rogers i believe who are
trying to follow and and yeah so
directly into the mic please get it
close to you
mr mr ripple would you help him with the
mic i i'd really like it clear
do you still have a question
no just one page i'm just trying to
catch up where we're at
and we were we were talking about
so
so do you have a question or are you
okay
all right no no sweat representative
walls
yeah
i think representing the hatch still
needs a redline copy of this he doesn't
have that and i don't know who has them
around here
you got an extra right there we're we're
we're leveraging representative long's
homework
we're
leveraging representative long's
homework this is his document it's got
his notes and markups on it
no problem
there's no reason to proceed if we're
not learning something so
what number are you on now seven i think
we're on to seven which is at page two
and again in response to feedback we
received we determined that it was a
good idea to expand the
facilities that
people resided in to include
institutions that may have pre-existed
okay i have a question about that it's
you know i can see what you're trying to
include i just want to make sure i i
know that we're excluding things like
for example somebody placed in a foster
home would would they qualify or not
no because they are
not in a facility that housed
adjudicated youth or detained youth
awaiting adjudication
thank you
uh question by representative long thank
you mr chairman with respect to seven
would that be only juvenile petitions
that
had a petition
against them
clear is that a clarifier that would be
my understanding that they would not be
at the facility unless they were either
being detained
prior to
adjudication or had been adjudicated
moving on to
number eight
you'll see we've
clarified the definition of sexual abuse
and that's because in our research we
uh
determined that under the applicable
case law
in prosecuting criminal claims that
coercion can actually be a requirement
under the
relevant criminal statutes that we
uh identified as a part of the
definition of sexual abuse so even
though
a
victim
even though consent is not a defense
to
the crime
it still requires an element of coercion
to prosecute someone they have to have
taken some affirmative act
to try to coerce the victim into
participating
we didn't think it was appropriate to do
that in this context we feel that there
is no situation
in which a staff member should ever have
been having sexual contact with a victim
even if there was consent and even in
the absence of an affirmative act so
that's the reason that we clarified the
definition so even if
the victim is
above the age of consent and the
allegation is the entire act was
consensual
this is intended to
say no there is no consent regardless of
the victim's age you you are correct uh
the question
yeah i guess i really have a question i
went back and read foss this morning and
i and i and i also looked at the statute
and the law i mean the statute has been
changed a little bit but with regard to
the element of an affirmative act that's
still in the law and i guess the thing
that concerns me a little bit is
the statute specifically talks the
criminal statute specifically talks
about an affirmative act being required
even in this circumstance and even with
a juvenile so i guess i'm really
troubled by the idea of why would we
why would we say
why would we make the state liable to
pay compensation for something that's
not
a violation of the statute
so i would give you two answers to that
um first is the the fact that um
looking for that affirmative act seems
appropriate when we are talking about
taking someone's liberty away and and
prosecuting someone criminally whereas
we're using a criminal definition but
this is really about civil
uh liability um so
the the second answer which is really
just an example of why is um you can
imagine a situation unfortunately where
a victim
would actually believe that
that they were going to have a
relationship with a guard when they
graduated from this facility
right and so
there might be no coercion or there
might be something that doesn't really
satisfy the criminal definition of
coercion
if that person is telling someone that
they really like them that they that
they want to marry them when they get
out um i don't think that would qualify
as coercion under foss but that i think
should qualify as a claim under this
under the statute vascular follow-up yes
so i i mean can you tell me i this is
something i didn't do but is i mean is
there a body an established body of
case law in the civil context that says
someone can be held liable in these
circumstances without
coercion because i guess what i'm
concerned about is if there is then
maybe that's one thing if there isn't
you know are we
would the legislature in some sense be
establishing
a precedent for other cases to say you
know the
the common law of new hampshire as sort
of supported by the legislature is that
you don't need that
i understand your your concern i would
refer you then to the cases that we
provided several sessions back in the
settlement and verdict research where
you'll see
quite a number of cases that have been
settled and the verdicts rendered and
the
kind of the view as to what constitutes
sexual abuse in the context of this
civil litigation arena
okay and and though and those do those
support the view that you don't need an
affirmative act there are very few
verdicts there are mostly settlements
and the and the
groups are not being
parsed by whether or not there was any
coercion that just seems to be the view
in those cases that
if there is sexual activity between
a staff member and an inmate for any
reason
even if it's consensual and even if the
staff member actually believes that
they're going to marry this child after
they leave the facility that that still
qualifies as something that needs to be
compensated
okay all right follow up are you okay no
oh go ahead representative walsh
is that true that there can be no
consent from somebody incarcerated be it
a child or an adult if there's a sexual
act there that because of the power
dynamic because somebody's being guarded
and somebody's an inmate there can be no
consent
right and that's the concept that we're
trying to capture with the language that
we've included um in this proposed
amendment for you um and the the anomaly
is just that under the criminal law
there is some case law out there that
even though that is accurate and consent
is is not a defense in the case of the
power uh disparity that you just
described there is nevertheless in order
to incarcerate someone a requirement
that the
defendant needs to have done something
affirmative to to cause the contact and
and what constitutes coercion under the
case law under foss gets into a murky
area that we didn't think we wanted to
deal with um in trying to adjudicate
follow-up are you okay
in light of the question it was asked i
mean if my understanding is that foss
specifically dealt with the issue that
representative walsh raised that that
even the statute says consent in the
under these circumstances cannot
cannot be given but the court
specifically said that's not enough to
meet the requirements of the
of the criminal law and i if i
if i understood what you said in
response to an earlier question i think
you're saying that there is no
there is no developed body of case law
in the civil area that says
you don't need some affirmative act
there's
there's you say there's a number of
cases have been settled but i don't
you haven't said that there's some
established body of case law that says
you don't need an affirmative act so i
haven't gone and researched exactly the
way you're phrasing this we can
certainly go back and look um and and
then address that further and
where we are right now is just based on
what i had previously described thank
you sure
so so let me summarize that in layman
language um uh i'm not an attorney uh a
fascinating conversation um as i
what we're not the judiciary we're a
finance committee okay and and so
um
i while i completely understand and in
to the notion that an incarcerated
individual is unable to consent just the
consent is off the table
um i i am concerned that if this is the
first legislative act
establishing it in our statutes that for
all civil procedures
this precedent would would hold because
we're passing a law
i'm uncomfortable with that i i think
that would be something that would need
to run through the judiciary for example
and
and so it so i do appreciate you saying
you're going to research this and do
some homework if you could maybe offline
stay in touch with the representative
lynn i i again i deferred to your
professional judgement i just wanted to
let you know
um i i i think we're better staying in
our lane and arlene is not creating new
judicial
precedent for civil procedure
i appreciate that and i think we could
probably address that as well by making
clear that
nothing about the administration of this
claims process is to be taken as a
precedent for other litigation purposes
representative walsh
attorney general ramsey just said what i
was going to basically reinforce and
that is this is this is a very narrow
thing in the statute limited to this
system and it is not precedent for other
civil cases out there it's very clear
that it's a limited
um
situation where coercion would not be
required
you okay
well i mean i guess
that then the question would become why
why is it you know why is it
appropriate in this case as opposed to
any other k i mean suppose that there's
you know
uh a case suppose we have a new facility
you know we we replaced the sununu
center with a new facility a couple of
years from now and something like this
happens um is the law
you know what would be the reason for
saying that you know the law shouldn't
be as it as it now would be under this
case i'm i'm just concerned about
uh you know
why are we carving out a spec
please don't misunderstand me i'm very
sympathetic to victims that were that
that were abused but why are we carving
out a special
uh
circumstance for this case sure no and
it's a great question um i think that uh
if we were to make clear that this was
not to be automatically taken as
precedent for future litigation purposes
that's not going to preclude lawyers
from arguing that for the same reasons
we decided to do it here they might want
to the courts might want to expand the
law or might want to apply it but i
wouldn't want it to be taken as an
automatic expansion of the law i would
want the judiciary to be able to
to consider that in the fullness of a
developed record in an individual case
i i think we're ready to go to the next
point
yeah okay i think i think we've made it
number nine yeah which is uh
which you'll find at page three lines
so again in response to concerns raised
we've considered whether
the
just notice within the state and just in
the old traditional way of publication
in a newspaper
locally would be sufficient notice and
on consideration we've expanded
the notice requirements to include
at least one national publication and
within the administrator's discretion
to publish in social media outlets
again we had uh requests to consider
doing much more than that but
i've
looked into the expense
and what would be involved in some of
those things and our our judgment was
that the best would best thing to do
would be to leave it to the
administrator to make those decisions
rather than
tie the administrator's hands regarding
for example using youtube or twitter or
all of the various platforms that were
suggested to us
those are significantly
cost prohibitive in some cases and i
would want the administrator to make the
determination whether or not
to um that the expense was justified so
so this causes me to to jump ahead and
and
you're going to
recommend i believe the creation of an
administrator to just manage the whole
program
um
is it in that i i'm not there yet is it
in the administrator's charge to act as
a fiduciary and manage administrative
costs
wisely is there is that part of their
accountability or or are they going to
have a
sort of a built-in incentive to
advertise and spend tons of money just
because you're they can't be wrong if
they do that
right so there's a tension there um but
the
reason for the move to a more
independent administration
was concerns that
victims
needed to feel protected in this process
in order to protect participate so um
the the guard rails on the
administrators expenses if you will is
that the administrator will be making
annual reports to the legislature
which will include information about the
expenses that have been incurred and
that are anticipated to be incurred
uh and
and
we would anticipate also that in the
uh search for and and
selection of an administrator that the
attorney general's office would be
involved and would be
making sure that the billing process
that would happen by the administrator
would be something that where the
state's interests would be protected
all right all right on the list of 100
things we need to worry about with this
program this is this is like in the 90s
cautious overspending to get the word
out because getting the word out is
critical to this program and the
perception that it's fair um i i just
want to make sure that we're not
creating a
a bad incentive to just grossly
overspend right and that we share that
concern
so first representative walls and then
representative lynn
thank you is there a national database
out there where we can
input
the
former residents of these institutions
and find out if they are incarcerated
somewhere outside the state of new
hampshire so that either the state or
even the plaintiff's attorneys could
have access to that information and
could reach out to those potential
victims even though they're they're
currently incarcerated around parole or
probation outside the state of new
hampshire
i believe law enforcement has access to
a database like that i don't on the
civil side we do not have access to
something like that
could we do something to to make that
kind of access for to the administrator
to somebody for purposes of informing
these victims of what their rights are
we we can certainly look into that um
that's a
we we had not
included a suggestion that notice would
go out to every former resident of the
facility because that would be an
enormous process to try to locate those
those individuals but the idea that we
might just locate people that are
currently incarcerated in other states
is something we can look into
representative yeah i have i have this
is probably the area that i have the
greatest concern uh from
from changing the original proposal and
i guess i have several uh
concerns just to start
from the beginning i mean
um
it strikes me that
at least as i anticipated and correct me
if i'm wrong under the original proposal
the administrator would be either the
attorney general or someone that the
attorney general designated within his
office
correct
under this it would be an attorney in
private practice and so i guess in terms
of the cost
i mean just at you know at the at the
initial level my suspicion would be
that if let's even let's assume that
this process went on for you know a
period of
three or four or five years
that
the difference in cost between
what somebody even a senior person in
the attorney general's office would be
paid over five years and what a lawyer
in private practice would be paid over
five years would be
very very significant
so let me ask are we effectively on line
10 now because of the
the way the conversations matured yes i
think 10 11 uh we can talk about
together and are sort of a part of this
conversation so i'd like you to go ahead
and address representative lynn's uh
question i i our clerk is using your
summary sheet to keep track of where
we're at for the minutes so okay
and i'm sorry no you're great that's i
guess the only thing i would say i am so
honored to have you
on this committee you do whatever you
want and will adapt well no no you know
what the only reason i i said this is i
just to avoid confusion because in item
10 you mentioned i think correctly that
the change to the
the change in the way the administrator
operates apply goes throughout the
statute it's not just in one or two
places it really goes kind of throughout
the statute that's right so i and i was
raising just the the first concern i had
is simply a money concern that it seems
that
if we're going to get and i assume we
would all everyone would agree claimants
the attorney general's office all of us
would agree that if we were going to
select an outside attorney we would want
a very competent experienced you know uh
well thought of attorney to do this
and it strikes me that
to get someone in private practice that
meets those qualifications
uh and and determine what you know what
you're likely to have to pay that person
is a lot more
uh than what you would likely pay
someone in the who was working in the
attorney general's office even if the
person was a very senior well-qualified
fair impartial et cetera person in the
attorney general's office right i i feel
the same way that you do about the this
this revision is going to increase the
cost of administration
and and
and the
the trade-off for the balance is um
trying to have an independent
administrator but also trying to control
those costs which is why the attorney
general's office is not completely out
of the process when we get to um item
items 10 and 11 or if we're there now
the um the idea is for the attorney
general to um try to resolve the claims
directly with the claimant and then if
the claimant is not satisfied that the
process would then move into an uh an
administrator's kind of resolution
proceeding
but in that way we would hope to keep
the costs down still i've also inquired
um
we had actually thought maybe a a
retired judge or a mediator would also
be a good candidate for this um
in
in my experience
working with receiverships which also
involve a claim process
that
the claim
the the work that is done does not get
billed typically at a lawyer's rate for
litigation it's typically somewhat less
because you do not have the overhead
that you have with maintaining a law
office
so i wouldn't expect typical litigators
rates but i agree with you this is going
to increase the cost by having an
independent administrator but we felt it
was necessary in order to
give claimants a level of comfort that
they would actually use the process
go ahead and follow up follow up so i i
was did you have any discussion or was
any thought given to the idea of
possibly
amending the the proposed legislation to
say that
you know an administrator will be hired
uh to do just this work but will be
employed
uh in the attorney general's office or
maybe some other agency of state
government
um you know at a at a determined salary
as opposed to
you know getting bills for even even at
a discounted rate i suspect it would be
i think the attorney would like to pipe
in on that one sure yeah i think the
answer would be we didn't discuss that
specifically but that goes to
something i wanted
to just add into attorney ramsey's
response i mean my thought is this if we
were to go this route and and look to
select an independent administrator we
would consider those types of options it
would not be my intent to to immediately
default to to hiring someone who would
then bill us hourly over and over again
and really jack up the administration
costs so i think the language as this is
written would potentially
allow for something like that but i
think that's something we could think
about because i
i
i agree with your concerns about
expenses i think we want
the idea is we want someone more
independent but we don't want to
hire a consultant right or a consultant
firm that has the administrator in it
that is then going to bill us at
exorbitant rates and trust me i'm very
sensitive to that because i deal with
that on all of the matters the office
deals with and that's something we we're
always
we're always thinking about and we make
very strong efforts to get better deals
and better rates because we're we're
just a larger client and we're also
state government and not not some large
private corporation sure so it's it's
it'll absolutely be top of our mind and
i think that type of discussion is one
we could have around this concept of
trying to preserve independence but also
keep costs down
may i ask another follow-up yes sir this
and again this goes to the idea of the
administration the
two things that kind of concern me about
the this system that you're talking
about here is
in contrast to the original
proposal if i understand correctly here
the administrator
would be the fi there would be one
administrator who would be the final say
for all the cases
whereas under the
under the original proposal
the final say if if the claimant didn't
like what the administrator did the
final say would be with an arbitrator
and the arbitrator might
you know might or might not probably
would not be the same in all the cases
um
so that
i mean that it seems to me that's a
that's a pretty big difference
because it may
which i i suppose could have various
implications
um
but i wonder if you could talk to why it
makes sense to have
you know
one person be the final voice without an
appeal
for
every for all the cases yep yeah i'll
i'll start and then i i definitely want
to then pass it over to attorney ramsey
so i don't miss anything but
i think there's a couple issues there
the first is the way this is set up is
even though the administrator would be
independent and there would be one
administrator
it's still kind of a similar process to
what we had before and that there would
be
an initial chance for
the ag designee and the claimant to
interact and for the ag designee to
present a view of the claim and what
they thought the claim should be valued
at
and the claimant could agree to that
if there if the claimant doesn't agree
as the language now says the
administrator would schedule a
resolution process
and that's when you would really go
before the administrator and the
administrator would make a make a
binding decision so
on that issue i think
i think the process is still fairly
similar but what you have is you have a
more independent administrator who's
taking in the claims and running the
process the ag designee would still have
an initial opportunity to try to resolve
the claim
before you went before the administrator
to your second point which i think is is
a good one and it is something i've
thought about
there is a big difference between
or there's a difference between
the pre this version in the previous
version because i think you're right
if if something were submitted to
arbitration you're not guaranteed to
always have the same arbitrator and that
presents i think additional risk to to a
claimant and perhaps
lessens the incentive to go to
arbitration it also presents additional
risk i think to to the state because i
there there are factors to consider on
both sides there
and one factor i think about is that if
we have one administrator who's
independent who's becomes very familiar
with this process is very familiar with
the guidelines
who we would on the front end make sure
at least from our perspective has an
outlook about this entire process that
makes sense
i think you could argue and i
i've been persuaded that that actually
might provide more
certainty that
that the outcome is fair the there
there'd be there could be a worry that
if
claims that went to arbitration
went to a different arbitrator every
time
you'd have results that
could really deviate from one another
they might be within the guidelines that
we establish but one arbitrator
you know might look at things
differently so
from another so
i think there are there are some risks
to it but i think there are also
potential benefits and when we balance
all of that with
with what i think is the major benefit
to persuading victims for to participate
and that is the the independence and
their feeling that they'll get a fair
shake that that's
we thought about all of that when
deciding to at least put this change
forward is something we thought we could
recommend um i want to make sure i
didn't miss anything so i do want to
pass it over to jen
i think the only thing i would add is
that if you have uh when you think about
the cost of the administrator is
compared to the cost of a number of
different arbitrators um it's an
incremental difference but it's not as
as large of a difference as it might
otherwise be no no i think you make very
valid points i mean that's why we have
you know we've we established a business
court we're talking about possibly
establishing a land use docket so they
have one i mean those are very valid
points that's just one other follow-up
the last point i had is if as i
understand the way
this is structured
i'm concerned that the administrator
if i understand it would know
under this procedure in other words if
the the attorney general and the
claimant
were not
able to come to an agreement the
administrator
as i understand it and correct me if i'm
wrong the administrator would know
at the time the administrator got the
case to decide
what the last offer was from the
attorney general and what the last uh or
the last offer what what the what each
party's position was on each side of the
issue
at the time the administrator got to
decide the case
and i'm a little concerned that that
you know as a practical matter that
probably cabins
the administrator i mean it would be
that's you know that's the reason
generally settlement discussions are not
allowed to be introduced in a in a trial
and so is there
you know could this be structured in a
way that that
that
the administrator would not know that
information
i think it certainly could that's not
something i think we had had
contemplated that the administrator
would necessarily know
that what the last offer had been i
think we intended to structure it that
the claimant could
decide that it was happy with what the
attorney general designee valued the
claim at in which case the parties would
tell the administrator that they'd
agreed to an award and that the
administrator didn't need to give any
further attention to the claim um or if
not then the claimant would ask for an
administrator resolution proceeding so
so you wouldn't have any you wouldn't
have any problem then if the if
if the language was toyed with a little
bit so that it would be clear that the
administrator
in that circumstances couldn't know what
the
what either side's uh
you know position was on dollars so to
speak would just know that they hadn't
come to an agreement right no i i
are you done represent blind
representative emery
thank you
as we're talking about money it occurred
to me that later on there's guidelines
for maximum fees for the attorney
plaintiff's attorney
at what point does it jump 25 to 33 in a
third percent let me just put a more
rounded question on that if it's to the
attorney's advantage to go to the
administrator
where the 33 and a third kicks in as
opposed to the 25
then administrators can be very busy
if money is a motivator
i and i don't i haven't read all this uh
changes to know when does that kick in
yeah i think you're correct that it it
would jump to the 33 and a third percent
if it moved from a resolution with the
attorney general to a resolution with
the
administrator and i think um
it's a it's a good question i think
if it goes to a resolution proceeding
though that attorney is going to need to
do additional work to participate in
that proceeding and so
would be making those decisions that you
just described in light of
the fee may get bigger but he's rolling
the dice that would the award get bigger
i i might do better i might not do as
well as what the attorney general's
office has offered so i don't think just
the incentive of possibly getting a
larger fee alone would be the only
reason that someone would choose to move
to a resolution proceeding
okay
but but but it could be right because
we're going to make the settlement fund
award and release document and some form
publicly available and so the plaintiff
attorneys are going to have develop
rapidly a track record on the generosity
or
or parsimony of the
of the administrator so
i i i talked to the attorney general
about this i i'm just trying to make
sure that
our incentive system is is right we we
we want them to settle sooner
to the
to make sure
as long as we're taking care of the
justice part of it but i
i don't want to create a casino
environment where they go gaming the
system right
um and i i think we've tried to capture
that with the way that we have
structured it and we can certainly
continue look at that
uh thank you and then as uh
representative lynn was talking i i was
putting on my old manpower analysis hat
and i was trying to think through
the the way that we can imagine the
workload hit hitting the administrator
and i imagine the workload will be
relatively high pretty quickly
and then it will
peak probably within the first six
months to
12 months
and then it's going to start to have a
tail and that tail by this is expected
to potentially be 10 years
right i think if i understand it right
so so my my what i don't know if i
really have a question in here as much
as i just have a curiosity is is if
there gets to be a point where the
natural workload
seems to have been done at the
three-year point or something like that
do we have an off-ramp to excuse the
administrator
short of four cause
or do we need one what do i maybe that's
really the first question for you is do
do we need an off ramp or are we going
to keep an administrator for 10 years
so it's it's an interesting thought the
current structure is that the
administrator would be reporting
regularly to the legislature and that
there's provision that the administrator
could wrap this up sooner than 10 years
if the workflow did what you just
suggested we'll have the claims window
will close after some period of time so
the universe of claims that need to be
dealt with will become finite and and
they will be making predictions to you
about um how many are left to be
resolved so
at some point you could naturally look
at this and say i think we should move
the lap state up and dismiss the
administrator and that would be a a
minor legislative act i would think
okay so you're you're saying that you
believe that the discretion is
completely in the hands of the
legislature to terminate the
relationship or are you saying the
administrator needs to make a motion or
something to terminate or
where where does that
discretion lie so i don't think we have
language in the bill right now that
would address that specifically and i
think i think the attorney general may
have some comments
yeah thank you representative and i know
we we discussed this earlier in the week
yeah the bill right now doesn't provide
a mechanism for removing the
administrator in in an instant in
whatever circumstances you may want to
remove them under i think we do need to
think about that
because
i think we would all hope that this
process would go well but there's any
reason why
you might want to remove
a state official for example and there
are processes to do that i think we that
is something we need to think about is
what mechanisms would we provide for
removal of the administrator under
various circumstances that we could
imagine which you might want to remove
them i think then to your point
you know what mechanisms are there to
to
to end the process when when there's no
longer a need for it
i i think the bill contemplates just
that the process would end naturally
when all the claims have been disposed
of but but we can think about that
as well i'm not as concerned about the
second point as i am about the first
which i think is something we should we
do need to think about there needs to be
there's really no state official or
anyone unappointed under state law who
who can remain in their position forever
and
regardless of what happens or whether
they commit malfeasance or whether
there's cause to remove them so i think
we need to think about think about that
thank you i want to do a sidebar real
quick uh representative umberger would
would you remind me when
this group needs to be done
with what it wants to recommend to the
yes
do you need a moment to think about that
no
it has to be reported
out
okay so
mr attorney general
you you and attorney ramsey are talking
about going back and doing some thinking
deeper on a few things
what
how are you feeling about um the amount
of time
i am confident that we can
so i guess it depends on where we end
today and what we think the the full
scope of the issues are that we still
need to address but
i have been aware of the march 10th
timeline this entire time and it's been
you know i've been thinking about it
we will i'm confident that we can think
about whatever issues are presented and
come back to you with proposed language
with plenty of time for you to consider
it and get the bill to a point where it
could be reported out by march 10th if
that's ultimately where you get to okay
thank you
so
so when last we looked at the summary i
i think we had just knocked out 10 and
yep and and number 12 is language that
appears on page three
uh at the bottom continuing on to the
and again this is just some language to
strengthen um
the perception on the behalf of of
claimants that this is
this is a process they can choose to
participate in but they're not required
to
and then
again strengthening that to make sure
that
they understand the
the decision that they're making and
enter into entering into this process
that we would
make sure they understood that they had
a right to consult with an attorney
since we are asking them to
commit to this process with a waiver of
rights to continue in litigation as a as
a part of their determination to
the next item is on page seven at light
lines one through ten
we had some further thinking about
uh
how the administrator might utilize
installment payments in resolving claims
and wanted to make clear that that that
would be something about which the
claimant would primarily
uh get to decide and only in the case of
uh a claimant who wished to receive
periodic payments or a situation that
was so clearly uh warranted that kind of
um
treatment that
that that would
that would be the only circumstance in
which that would be utilized
uh representative
so yeah i think i i mean i i agree with
sort of the first part of that it seems
to me that it does make i mean a
claimant should
if if if you decide if if the state is
going to pay somebody the claimant
should decide whether they get it in an
installment or not i guess i'm a little
bit
the last part of it uh
you know a compelling need to protect
the interests of the claimant
[Music]
i guess i'm
that has a little bit of the sort of
nanny state
part to it and i'm wondering
you know if the claimant
if the claimant and the claimant's count
who's represented by council say
we want the money right now
the whole thing and the claimant's
competent
um
what's the basis you know
to say you know
well you're really not very responsible
you're going to blow it all in a year so
we're not giving it to you
so
yep um i can
i understand the concern it does it is
an exercise a little bit in paternalism
uh it it is limited to large awards
and it uh
it certainly is not something that has
to be included but we thought it would
be something that you might want to
consider doing since
uh there there
is a fair amount of information
out there in the literature that
sometimes receiving an enormous amount
of money right up front can actually be
harmful to a victim
it it it can have all kind believe it or
not it can have all kinds of traumatic
effects on the individual to
to suddenly receive that kind of an
amount of money
sure i'd even say professional athletes
have that problem i mean and they're
they're supposed to be competent so uh
go ahead representative lindsay i'm
wondering i mean would it make sense to
put
something more specific into what the
administrator would have to find to be
able to
because i i mean i
again it just
it just i it just seems to me to be
pretty distasteful for for an
administrator to be able to say with a
competent claimant represented by
competent counsel who say we want the
money now
for the you know the administrator to
say
what you're not
you're not responsible enough or your
lifestyle
demonstrates that you're not responsible
enough to get the money you know i
mean i i agree with you on the on the
sports figures but they do get them you
know they they do get the money and are
allowed to blow it right 75 blow it and
so yeah representative erf do you
question would you mind if i respond oh
go oh go go ahead yeah so i i definitely
see the concern and we're wrestling with
it
there's a couple issues i just wanted to
point out one
you know we certainly don't want to be
paternalistic and we certainly don't
want to
um not have respect for the victims
i do think it's important to remember
that that many of these victims are
individuals who
have suffered a lot in their life not
just from abuse they may have suffered
at ydc but they may have suffered before
that they may have had really tough
times since that
whether we want the administrator to be
making you know compensated competency
determinations as you might make in the
criminal process i'd be reluctant to
have that but i i think that it makes
sense for an administrator who is
dealing with
individuals who may be dealing with a
lot some are maybe incarcerated some may
struggle with substance abuse some may
struggle with any number of issues to to
be able to
to have some discretion to make those
determinations i think with this
with uh this population it it makes
sense and i know there's there's no way
to say that without that sounding
perhaps a little bit paternalistic and a
little bit disrespectful i i that only
comes though from a place i think of of
legitimate concern on our part but i
think that's that's an additional factor
that i think is important to remember
here the the the specific individuals
that we are
dealing with or that we've seen so far
come forward
so i'm going to follow up on that and
then go to representative irf and
representative hatch but
um so
i i think we're probably all
in some
degree of agreement on the idea that if
the claimant is um
is credible and able to handle their
financial
duties uh that
lump sum is perfectly appropriate if
that's what they want
i i i think what where the discussion
should spend a little bit of time is to
say
to what extent does the administrator
have the ability
to inquire about
the claimant's competency
you know like for example let's say the
individual
has an active ongoing
drug problem
but there's not an open arrest there's
nothing
clearly in the public record about that
but but the person is incompetent
because they're
using drugs actively
how would this administrator even know
that and
you know what sort of power are they
going to have to inquire into the
personal competency of the individual
and i'm less concerned about
doling it out over time because i think
it also protects the state's interests
to spread out the financial payments and
to make sure that we don't create a new
dependent on the state welfare system
quickly because they blow through the
money i i think there's a state interest
in this but but where i'd get concerned
about the confidentiality and and and
the paternalism of it is when we start
to talk about the administrator's
authority to inquire into the personal
lifestyle of the claimant because i
think there are privacy bounds in there
and
what what are your thoughts on that
that wasn't something we had
contemplated that the administrator
would have some affirmative duty to
actively go investigate
i think the the intention of the
provision was to deal with the limited
circumstance in which an individual
presents maybe without counsel maybe
decides to to refuse counsel's
recommendation to take a
stream of payments fires this lawyer and
tells the administrator that he wants
the money uh immediately i don't i don't
anticipate that this is a provision that
would necessarily get invoked frequently
but it we thought it would be a good
option a good tool for the administrator
to have
in his tool belt in in that instance
um
and i
i
think that it's it's as you say it's a
it's a the ability for the state to to
uh spread those payments out but i don't
think that's the primary purpose of it
yeah so i i can believe it's a good tool
i just am trying to understand
what the flow of information would be to
allow the
administrator to make an informed
decision on whether or not they want to
overrule the request of a lump sum and
opt instead for a
string of payments i i don't i don't
understand that so i think that in the
in the part of the claim resolution
proceeding which is going to get built
out as a part of the
the work that gets done after the bill
is passed the administrator in
consultation with the attorney general's
office and the plaintiff's council is
going to build a process um that that's
something that could be addressed in
that process with lots of input from
plaintiff's council as well
thank you
representative thank you mr chair
i'd like to go back to costs if i may
i'm noting that when you eliminated the
arbitrator you eliminated the sharing of
expenses when you went to arbitration
that says to me
you've removed any incentive to settle
with the ag why would anybody waste
their time there when there's going to
be no costs associated with going to the
administrator
timing
you could you could get a resolution
with the attorney general's office as
quickly as 90 days under this uh
proposal
it's going to probably take much longer
particularly in the early stages of this
administration to get through a
resolution proceeding with an
administrator
a follow-up if i may
you're referring to the claimant's
concerns about getting paid quickly but
the attorney is probably driving the
process his attorney or her attorney
and they don't have any time incentive
they have a money incentive
i mean you took out a huge part of the
i think the balance in the in the prior
proposal yeah and and i i don't know if
we're going to use an independent
administrator that it feasibly makes
sense to ask the claimant to pay a part
of the administration costs
i also think that that was an area where
it didn't feel good to victims to have
to pay for the privilege of being heard
by the arbitrator and so the balance
that we're recommending
kind of leans the other direction but i
certainly understand your concerns
that's the reason we had initially
proposed
the the
the fee sharing
but
on further consideration
i think you know the overall
restructuring sort of makes more sense
to to have the administration fees be
are you okay
yes thank you uh representative hatch
you still have a question well thank you
mr chair i'm just thinking through this
and a lot of my questions have been
answered by your questions but
and just thinking this through and i
just put my own circumstances in play i
have six children they're all great good
kids
and five of them if they received a
bundle of cash would be very responsible
to it and and all good one not so much
but nobody would know that except mom or
dad or anybody close so is there a way
to allow
the administrator
to
dole out settlement
if he or she receives
proponents or germain information
uh from somebody that would maybe
want consideration of that
hopefully
some of these people have people close
around them that understand them
and maybe they would have an avenue to
present this information i don't know if
this makes sense or not uh hopefully
their attorneys if they have one
um
would maybe
aid in that event is there anything ever
done like that or is that
sensible or not for this i mean i don't
see an answer to this other than
you know what i mean
it's a tough question and ultimately
it's something that you all will will
decide what you think is is best and and
of course um
will
you know work with whatever you decide
the
i think what you're kind of describing
would be the possibility for for other
people to intervene maybe to express
their opinions
and i
i worry that that might um bog the
process down in such a way that would be
well
thank you for me
just a venue to allow it to be
considered is is all i'm thinking of and
not have a
pandora's uh box and end up being in any
state or an internal
thing just
some sort of venue and i and i think
let's not forget though also that
separate and apart from this process
people like you're describing there may
be other avenues within the legal system
for somebody to come and petition for a
guardianship
i think i think in an extreme case where
family members were concerned there
would be maybe other ways to address
representative mooney thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question at the time a claimant files a
claim
is the claim based solely on the events
that occurred while they were housed at
the detention center or can it and does
it branch out into extenuating
circumstances as an example what their
lives have been like
been out of work and so on so forth
it would just be based on events that
occurred
during their time at the detention
center
thank you
so so based based on um your
not just general knowledge of the cases
are we going to end up with any
situations where
there was contact post incarceration
between
the prisoners and the guards
that would also with that i would assume
that would become extenuating
circumstance if there was some kind of
an ongoing relationship post
incarceration is is that is that just
are we just talking about something that
didn't happen or or is that possible
i i think it's possible that that
happened
i don't think we contemplate though that
being considered as
as part of of this process i mean i
think where
that may come into play when you know
when when you're
looking at the likelihood that events
occurred while they were
incarcerated at a detention center but i
think we would not be considering
contact or events that occurred once
they were not in
in the relevant facility
thank you i i'm not familiar with these
cases i just i'm curious
if somebody is
willing to abuse their power as a guard
if are they predisposed to being a
stalker you know so
uh representative lynn
can i follow up just on on
representative mooney's question i guess
i'm not clear i mean wouldn't it be
wouldn't it be
not at all unusual for someone who was
abused who claims to have been abused at
the ydc to say as in support of their
claim for damages
well
as you know i maybe have an expert that
would support this well as a result of
that
you know
i
my you know my
excuse my language but my life turned to
and it turned to for a long
period of time so i you know i and as an
example you know i
um
i've i've
frequently lost my job or been fired and
you know maybe would have to have
evidence
so i i could see a number of
circumstances where things that happened
later
would be
very relevant to damages yeah
absolutely i i think i interpreted
representative mooney's question maybe i
interpreted it not not exactly correctly
kind of as representative edwards raised
like would there be events
that happened once they were not in the
facility anymore that may
be compensable
there would be a basis for liability as
opposed to like like if because i have
thought about this and we we have seen
these circumstances where there may have
been contact with an individual by a
staff member after they were outside of
the facility right so i don't think we'd
be considering those events
in a in a matrix or in a set of
guidelines when it comes to determining
compensation but as for whether events
that happened
after the facil after someone was in the
facility whether those would be
considered
in in deciding what what the damages
were or what the compensation should be
i think yes that would certainly
come into play
uh but that or at least it could
potentially come into play i think that
would depend
largely on how
how these guidelines end up getting
negotiated and how and how any claims
matrix ends up getting negotiated thank
you
so the one of the questions i was going
to ask you basically just answered but
what i wanted to say overall is i sort
of see this working the same way civil
claims work in the judiciary right now
and that is a measure of damages
includes harm that continues after the
act has happened so for example if you
broke your back and you can't work
that's part of the measure of damages
say in a traditional civil climb
similarly i would seem to me that
the judiciary has
sometimes they will do a lump sum award
and sometimes they pay the award over a
period of time if it's obvious that
there's going to be
expenses over a long period of time so
for example when you have a child that
is
born with disabilities and that can be
traced directly back to the birth
process and say you have a claim against
that ob gyn those claims can that amount
of money can be paid over a period of
time or putting a trust that goes over a
period of time it would seem to me that
the similar kinds of things could apply
here both for the measure of damages and
for the payment of it that we just use
the systems or were used as a precedent
the systems that are already in place
for civil damages
i wouldn't say you're wrong in thinking
about that i would answer your
question though just with uh
with i think what will be the answer but
also but also a comment
one of the things we're trying to do
with this process is is balance the need
to be able to
value these claims without
too much
um
how can i say it too much sort of
invasive questioning of how victims
lives have turned out you know after
they were incarcerated at at ydc or
after they were they were in ydc and so
while
i think while while those
well that could come into the discussion
i think what we would want not want to
do is end up in a situation where
you know beca horrible things happen to
a victim but because they were able to
pull their lives together you know they
they necessarily were compensated less
than someone who wasn't able to and it's
admirable when a victim can overcome
these types of events but i i don't
think we would
necessarily want to put ourselves in a
position where we're penalizing someone
for not overcome overcoming
things like that that happened to them
so so while i i do think we can
in valuing claims we can think about
what happens in the normal civil
litigation process this process is
designed to be different than that and
so i don't think
we that
the procedure for valuing claims will
will line up with traditional litigation
but isn't that part of the measure of
damages if you've got somebody that that
abuse that maybe they're
fragile emotionally because they had
other issues you know before they got
there
that would be the measure of damages if
they can't if somebody can hold a job
their measure of damages are going to be
different than somebody who can't hold a
job will never be able to hold a job
can't be in a relationship
you know it it seems to me that should
go to the measure of damages
right and that and that's why i'm saying
i don't think it would be irrelevant i'm
just making the comment that it's it
probably not necessarily to the same
extent as it would be if we were
litigating these cases in court
because it's
how this is going to end up how the
value how these claims are going to get
valued is going to be largely determined
by
the claims process that's set up and the
guidelines that are agreed to and any
value matrix that's agreed to so it's
hard for me to sit here today and and
and know
how much that's going to come into play
that's going to be a subsequent
negotiation that has to take place but
but my sense is that to the extent that
comes into play it will be less so than
in the traditional litigation process
because you're right representative if
we were litigating these cases in court
that would be important you know what
what are the damages that flow
from this harm i think we'll still want
to consider that but given the reality
that we're going to try to
design a very efficient process that
that
it can move quickly that is
um
not not too invasive and doesn't require
too much examination of a victim's life
i think
though it's just it's a reality that
those factors won't be taken into
account to the same extent they might
attorney ramsey i don't want to cut you
off
okay so
so as i listen to this it seems to me
like um
the
guideline matrix
that is going to be constructed
is going to be really kind of critical
to capture
a lot of this philosophical trade-off
sort of question that we're having and
and i've never
seen
a guideline like this i this is not my
domain
but i imagine that's going to be
critically important to this whole
process
what what
since that will occur after this
legislation is passed and after the the
house has dealt with this
what what process do you imagine
for just getting sort of a
legislative thumbs up on the uh
so
just for uh for a little bit of context
in some other um claims resolution
processes the matrix looks a little bit
like a chart of types of harm from from
very serious things down to not so
serious things with dollar amounts
assigned or ranges of dollar amounts
assigned for each type of harm that will
be able to be published and claimants
will know what their potential range of
recovery is going into this process so
to your question representative walls it
will be a little bit different than the
litigation process
and claimants will be able to choose
whether they want to go that traditional
litigation route and and have their
damages fully assessed like you're
describing or whether they would like to
participate in this alternative process
and know they'll know the range of what
they might be entitled to recover going
in
in terms of the design of the process
the bill does not currently um just
before we leave that so also i imagine
that part of that matrix is are the
extenuating circumstances that would
help decide what part of the range the
administrator would be on and and do you
think you you know enough to be able to
describe what the
extenuating circumstances might be will
that be public knowledge as well yeah
the gut
i think we contemplated that the
guidelines would be a document that
would include all of the factors that
might be go into the consideration of
where you would fall in the guidelines
um
things that have to do with
whether the claim has been raised any
time in the past
whether the
the amount of passage of time since the
claim whether the claim might have been
subject to legal defenses in the event
that it was
litigated all of those would be
articulated at the front end so that
claimants would understand the process
and then in terms of
did you so no i was just ready for you
to go into the process i didn't want you
to forget where you were before i
interrupted you sure no not a problem so
the um in terms of how that matrix would
be developed we've obviously already
been thinking about it and i'm sure
plaintiff's council has as well
it was contemplated that we would meet
and confer and then the administrator
would ultimately make the decision this
doesn't currently have a provision for
legislative approval of that but if you
wanted to include it
one thing we had contemplated at one
point was that we would adopt that by
rule at the attorney general's office if
we have an independent administrator
that might be more difficult to do but
if the legislature wanted to have
oversight of the matrix we could
certainly build that in
i i wouldn't be asking for anything
that's outside i this is not a normal
thing we're doing but i don't think it
goes completely without precedent so
whatever the whatever the appropriate
legislative oversight or or or
participation would be i would just ask
that you guys think about it and let us
know
yeah another option in addition to
adopting the the process by rule would
be for approval by the fiscal committee
say that's that's a
that's a fairly typical way to approve
something in a more efficient manner
because we all know the rulemaking
process is
is can take a while but um but we can
think about that i'm sure plaintiff's
counsel will also have something to say
about that yeah so i i would i would
definitely buy off on the idea that once
this is uh all set up that it should be
representative lynn may i just ask a
question really in follow-up to
representative walsh's question so if am
i understanding from what you're saying
that the matrix
would be
would be mostly concerned with the
what happened to the person
[Music]
sort of at the time of the abuse as
opposed to
sort of damage kind of things in other
words you would not have a
and i
you know i'm just sort of talking off
the top of my head but it would not say
if that for example if the person if the
victim
was na was never able to seek
uh was never able to obtain steady
employment
you know that that adds x
x dollars to the claim on the other hand
if the victim was able to receive steady
employment uh the victim
you know it's it's a it's a lower amount
because i think representative walsh's
point is that i mean it seems to me that
you know
if if if a victim you know
turned out to be uh the next steve jobs
uh we might say that you know it's
terrible what happened to you but your
damages are x and if if the
victim turned out to be like what what
what may happen to what we might more
typically think of happen to a a victim
then the damages should be significantly
higher i would think
yeah i think one of the
um
differences between a process like this
and and litigation is that that factor
is not going to be nearly as heavily
weighed i won't say that it might not
factor into the arbitrators thinking at
all but the alternative process is
actually
designed such that a steve jobs would
still be able to recover
based on what had happened to him at the
facility and i think that's because of
what attorney general uh formella said
that
we don't want to penalize a person um
because they've overcome the obstacles
that they were presented with we want
them to be entitled to recover based on
what happened not based on what what
they did later in life
right no sure i mean i understand see
you know even the steve jobs should get
something for having been abused but it
i that that that's different than saying
that it would you know it would not
what happened to the person later on as
a result of it would not have
any uh any any relationship to how much
i i think it
i think it certainly would have some
relevance my sense is it would it would
factor in less than the traditional
litigation process and i also think it's
it's difficult for us to i think to sit
here today and and
and speculate as to how much it's going
to factor in because i think that that
will be the subject of some pretty
important negotiations and and
discussions
representative edwards made the point
and it's a point i think we've we've all
known but we haven't gotten to in our
discussion so far what this
what this uh what these guidelines and
any value matrix look like are going to
okay
we've been at this for uh 90 minutes
nine zero and uh i
i think we're at a clean point we're
about to start line 14 is that right
yes
so i'm i'm proposing a uh
eight minute
sort of uh recess so that people can you
know uh
freshen up
so we will reconvene
uh
hey
keith
so
um
in order to make good on my word uh it's
uh 11 36 that's that's about eight
minutes
so um
i'm gonna
end the recess on this and uh the house
is now in um hearing again on hb 1677.
in the fashion of the old western serial
movies
when we last
left our intrepid hero we were on line
14.
uh line 14 is language on page four at
and this is language that
was considered
and included for recommendation based on
a comment that you had representative
edwards at the last hearing about
have the claimants file under oath and
be subject to referral over for for
uh misrepresentation should we also do
that with respect to the the
perpetrators that we may uncover during
this process i would love to say yes but
i but i think the better answer to that
question is uh only if the claimant
requests it
and so that's the purpose of that change
thank you yeah um
line 15 uh it's language found at page
four lines nine to fifteen
um again in response to things raised at
the last work session um we have
included specific language to make clear
that when claimants provide us with a
release that does not bar them from
continuing to pursue claims against the
perpetrators
represent lynn may i just ask a question
with regard to
14. i don't have any problem at all with
the language that says a claimant shall
not be required to cooperate in a
criminal investigation
as a condition of participating in the
claim process i have no problem with
that
the earlier sentence though
i guess which says that
perpetrators of sexual abuse identified
by claimants may be referred to an
appropriate law enforcement agency by
the administrator but only with the
consent i mean i
that strikes me as a
you know i guess i always
i was always under the understanding
that the state decided who gets
prosecuted and who doesn't not the
victim um and so i'm i'm kind of
concerned about
subjecting the state's discretion to the
the you know the victims
i mean certainly i'm sure the state
would take that into account but to say
that the victim controls
i seems to me to be
yep
so um i would just point out that this
is a language that refers to the
administrator but not to the state
nothing here would bar the state from
making a determination to prosecute
someone and as we're all aware there is
an investigation on going uh and so this
would just be whether or not the
administrator would independently make a
referral to the state for that
prosecution if the claimant did not wish
to do so in other words
we don't want to force the victims to
participate with the criminal
investigation if they simply don't want
to
just as a part of this process
okay
and were
the attorney general's office
involvement in this process will be such
that we i think we would see any
information that the administrator would
see that would lead to some
determination that there may need to be
a criminal review or criminal
investigation i don't think the
administrator
is going to get information that that
we're you know that you're not aware of
okay all right so i see your point so
the ag designee may take it and pass it
over to to
the criminal justice bureau but and the
criminal justice bureau can decide at
that point how to to approach it but the
administrator would not have an
obligation
on them to make a make a referral or
unless the victim consented and wanted
so the key sounds like um there there
would need to be some kind of a referral
do you
do any of you lawyers sense that that
referral process needs a mention in this
legislation or
is it it sounds like representative lin
as as long as as the as the attorney
general points out
the um
as long as the this is not construed to
limit the ag's authority to initiate
a criminal prosecution and i and it from
what you've said i take it you you don't
interpret it that way then i'm fine with
it
all right uh representative long i i
just i don't want to put you on the spot
but you had written a marginal question
here in your notes and i just want to
make sure if you had a question that we
got it addressed
we're on uh page four
um
topic 15 and your notes are on the right
it says something like
thank you mr chairman yeah the
perpetrator it it appears that that
would be the case i got my answer thank
uh i think we're ready to go
i i think we were ready to move on to
number 16 which is language found at
page 7
this is an improvement we recommend
based on concerns
that we don't want to
cloak this process completely in secrecy
and so we we would recommend that the
administrator also include basic
information about the nature of the
claims that are being made uh in the
public disclosure of what's going on at
the claim process without identifying
any claimant but
but the nature of the claims being made
so so i think we had a conversation on
this uh last time and um
and the attorney general has provided an
example of the settlement fund award and
release which is extremely helpful to to
to know what what you're going to
make exposable
what i had been asking was
for a template of the format of the
report that would come forward
but
maybe this is better
way to answer my question because this
is
i assume this is all the source
documentation and any sort of a summary
report would just a hundred percent be
summarizing these
yes i think that's correct in addition
to the the financial
uh information about the expenses of the
of the fund
okay so i'll withdraw my my request for
a template of the report because you've
uh on item
17 uh page 8 line 13
we've moved up the effective date to the
date of passage
uh number 18.
can we can we um go deeper there i i i
think associated with the effective date
conversation we also talked about the
wisdom of putting a suspense state on
this or not a suspense date what am i
looking for the the sunset date
did you guys think think about or talk
about a potential sunset date on this
legislation
there is there is
a provision of the legislation that we
would hope uh
survived sunset and i think other than
that provision we could include it and
that's the provision that talks about
once publication is made we would treat
that as
notice
to the to the community for purposes of
limitations
so that if someone were to come along
and file a claim 10 years from now
those claims would be subject to
the legal effect of having had notice of
your right to bring a claim earlier
so i'm interpreting that to say that
there is a section of the legislation
that should survive but the rest of it
can be closed down and so for the parts
that can be closed down
is
as a legislator i i think there's value
in having sort of a self-cleaning
attribute to the legislation to remove
itself when it's no longer relevant
i
agree with you and i think we can
include that although we haven't yet all
should the legislation be removed
until such time as the 10 years
of
um
you know claiming you know paying out
the claims
shouldn't that be the sunset of this
i'm just saying that you know we don't
want to sunset the legislation when
there's still in fact maybe claims
to be paid out through whatever the date
was 2032. so that's that's what i took
as the sunset date for this for this
legislation
i i don't disagree i i just would like
whatever the proper way of saying that
for us to consider it and put a sunset
date on the portions of this
law that could be sunset
at that point
or at whatever point that seems like an
appropriate date to me
okay
com comment representative umber
no i'm fine okay
we want our
victim witness advocates to participate
in development of the claim
process
and recommend that as a an additional
source of input
and similarly
item 19
which is in a couple of places a couple
of lines on page five and then
a couple of lines on page six again
uh
we recommend that you include the right
of the victims to have an advocate
there to support them as they're going
item
if
if i could just just ask a question
um in the normal
process
if a person is represented by counsel
does the victim witness still get
involved
yes i i think so okay i just
i don't have an i i mean this is a good
thing i just wanted to make sure that
this is not one of those precedent
setting things but
rather the normal process for this sort
of thing i i think they might still have
the right to do it even though the
language wasn't in the bill
but um
but i think it's good to make clear to
victims as a part of making sure they
understand and are comfortable with the
item 20 is at
this is an inclusion that came out of
discussions
that we had with the administrator of
the
um
process for the diocese in new york um
one of the things that she stressed was
that it was important to victims to be
able to sit down face-to-face
with the administrator and feel that
they had been heard
and to do that in a private setting
without the attorney general's office
present
and that
seemed like a very good idea to the idea
to us and we recommend that you include
item 21
page five lines 8 through 30 is to
clarify that the investigator will just
serve as a independent fact finder
and won't be making
recommendations for resolution
that's consistent with kind of the shift
of this bill to create a more
independent process
yes representative that's great can you
other than this
other than the uh
the new york example um is is this
something that is
kind of standard i mean it does strike
me to be
particularly since the the the victim
will have an opportunity if the victim
wishes
to testify before the administrator
um
to allow the you know
a person who is an adult to have with
their counsel sort of an ex parte
meeting with the decision maker does
seem to me to be
you know a bit unusual and so i'm
wondering if if this is is there any
other examples besides the new york one
um
that administrator has actually
administered quite a number of um
similar proceedings and it's something
that they've incorporated in their
process is my understanding
across the board i don't know beyond
that particular administrator of
examples where that's been incorporated
it is not consistent with sort of the
judicial way of usually resolving claims
but since a part of this process is
about sort of healing and at the point
that
this occurs this individual will not be
going to court because there will have
been a waiver of litigation rights so
with all of those considerations and
this trying to be an alternate process
for these folks um we
thought it was in the balance better to
i mean i guess one of the other things
and this is maybe a bit
uh it goes a bit beyond this particular
thing but
um
that sort of
assumes that
there's no question
about the claim i mean it's the
you know i mean don't get me wrong i'm
sure that many of these claims are valid
claims that should be compensated but i
guess i you know
i'm not sure that we can say that all of
them fall into that category and so if
there's
you know if there's a contested case
where there's really a cl really a
question
did the abuse occur
um
to allow the
the uh
the victim to have a an ex parte
stab at the at the judge so to speak it
seems to me to be
um i'm i'm very troubled by that idea so
i i wouldn't think it would be the only
information that the administrator would
consider so if there was some question
if whether or not the abuse actually
occurred that would
happen during the the attorney general's
office would have an opportunity to
participate in and
try to
elucidate that those issues during a
different phase of the claims resolution
process
that's to be developed
once the administrator is appointed and
with all of the parties in consultation
so you don't see that in this
legislation yet but um
it's i understand your concern um and i
i
i think
that
it's not
something that absolutely has to be
included but it's a recommendation that
we think
would help victims to feel like they
want to use this process and
um
that the process helps them to have some
i'd like to just add
a couple comments to that i think that i
definitely see your concern
representative lin that
you know we wouldn't want to set up a
situation in which
a claimant a victim
can have a private conversation with the
administrator perhaps tell give the
administrator information that the ag
designee doesn't know they're alleging
and
and make a case without an opportunity
for
you know the ag designee to respond
right and
and and perhaps present an alternative
view of what happened i don't think that
that's not the intent of this i mean the
intent is to
to give
the claimant
their opportunity to just talk
face-to-face with the administrators say
what happened to them if this process is
working the way it's intended they will
already have submitted that information
when they submit the claim and so i i
think we could probably build in
safeguards to ensure that while they get
a private face-to-face meeting with the
administrator
to the extent information is conveyed in
that meeting that has not been conveyed
in any other way that information needs
to be shared with the ag designee but
perhaps the administrator could do that
you know
i think the point of this is
giving it's really about i think what
what can be a powerful
outlet for victims giving them the
opportunity to have the just that
private face-to-face meeting with the
decision maker but it's not intended i
think
as you are concerned with and now that
you mentioned i think it's a legitimate
concern that we need to think about it's
not intended to to give
give a victim
a free shot at the judge so to speak and
convey information that the the attorney
general designee is not going to have an
opportunity to respond to
can i have a follow-up you know i'm just
wondering i mean couldn't you since
these proceedings are going to be
private not you know sort of not open to
the public couldn't you accomplish the
same thing by having something that
would say
you know the the uh
the victim shall have an opportunity to
personally address
the administrator uh at some point
during the proceedings but you know that
would be
that would be in the presence of the
of the
uh
attorney general's representative
so something like that
i think it's absolutely something we we
can think about
and because i i see i see the concerns
because we're sort of we're trying to
create what's
in some ways a mediation and arbitration
and an administration of claims and it's
kind of all in all in one right and so i
think in balancing all those you know
we need to make sure we balance it
correctly and in trying too much to crea
create give an outlet we don't give what
essentially would be a
a competitive advantage in in what is
still
at least softly can be an adversarial
proceeding if the aeg designee has a
different view of the claim than than
the claimant
thank you yeah so representative
emmerich and then representative walls
thank you mr chair
um
this seems to me to be the grease skid
to move
every case into the administrator
uh
and and the claimant
are they going to know that the price
just went up
you know because if i'm if i'm
representing a bunch of people i'm going
to say gee you really ought to talk to
the administrator
i mean and it brings no value to the
case but if the if the attorney says you
should really talk to the administrator
boom 33 and a third percent from 25
for one conversation and as a claimant
they didn't you didn't tell me that
well you didn't read the law okay i i
think this is a really bad idea
based on
i'm looking for the dollars and cents
side now
i understand from a human side why this
is a good idea but i think you could
almost
put somebody over in the corner that
says
the public here here's your chance to
talk
go for it and it doesn't have to be the
administrator
you know what i'm saying it could be a
cardboard character for crown out loud
it just
i think this is a bad idea
for process purposes than financial
reasons
i'm hearing your comments and i
understand them i think we need to give
that some more thought as well um
the goal would be to to help the victim
with healing but the we need to think
about the financial consequences of of
having people choose the choose the
process in the way you're describing
thank you
representative walls
um you know one of the things all my
terms my four terms on children and
family law and national conference of
state legislators sent me out to
national conferences
teaching me about trauma informed care
and trauma-informed processes and what
i'm hearing from some of my friends on
the committee is
a concern that's a very legal concern
but doesn't recognize that this is a
trauma-informed process and that under a
trauma-informed process
you need to have some unique things like
the victim have the opportunity to speak
to the administrator
and
i'm wondering if we can't recognize this
as a trauma-informed process continue to
have that ex-party meeting
not have it trigger necessarily go up to
a 33 percent i don't think it has to to
trigger that i think it's not the same
as a full back and forth on behalf of
the the lawyers of an advocacy just one
meeting
but i think we've got to recognize that
we have
very traumatized victims and we need to
continue to have a trauma-informed
process that has processes that are
outside the traditional civil approach
to these kinds of things and that that's
the whole point of this is that this is
a trauma-informed process that allows
things that are non-traditional to occur
i'm going to take a shot at that just
first
so representative walls i i i i hear you
i share your concern i think the ag
came in here today with a proposal
that was very centered around how to
respect the the trauma-informed
intervention
uh and and what we're hearing is that
there's a another possibility in this
world of ours which is that somebody
could come up with a
false
accusation
and in that situation if they
strictly and completely a moment of
quiet with the administrator where they
can say pretty much they want
whatever they want without challenge
that can create
an unreasonable risk to the to the state
and so
what what i hear what we're asking the
ag to go away with is
is to just rethink through this how do
we maintain the integrity
of the the trauma
scenario that we're dealing with while
still finding a way to protect
the state's interests too and but i i'm
okay with the first priority being
worrying about the trauma environment
that the victim is in i just i just
don't i just don't want to accidentally
give that
give an error do well a shield
i would agree representative i just
didn't want the opportunity for a
victim to meet privately with the
administrator to disappear because i
think that is part of a trauma-informed
process i think these victims are going
to be totally intimidated by a
traditional process and i think that
that just as the the
mediators and other things have learned
that that's an important part of a
process when you have these kinds of
victims
that's why i wanted to address it
thank you so now that you've just heard
the sidebar do you want to jump into the
i think there's a way that we can
separate the
the um face to face
from the
uh adjudicative process and make both
available so that the victim can
be heard and have the healing without
that triggering the um the economic
yeah i guess i mean one of the things
you know i again i i guess where i
differ with representative walsh is i
think that
we need to recognize that this
you know particularly if you're talking
about something that happened a long
time ago where the the alleged abuser is
no longer is dead or no longer around or
whatever
there is a ripe opportunity for someone
who would want to take advantage of the
system to take advantage of the system
and there needs to be ways to ensure
that that doesn't happen and for example
i you know one of the things that i i
absolutely object to
is
is that on page four
the in subsection f the where the
the uh
where it says claim shall be submitted
under oath and shall be presumed to be
truthful i would absolutely take that
out i mean you know why are why are
these claims to be
presumed to be truthful any more than
any other claims in any other setting it
just seems to me
um
you know the
the claimant i would assume has at least
some burden to come in and say and and
convince
uh the attorney general in the first
instance or the administrator eventually
that in fact what they say happened
actually happened
i i i think the
the wisdom of that and whether we should
do that is for you all to decide based
on the discussion you're having right
now i can tell you the reason that we
included that language was to um
provide
the
incentive to victims to come forward and
to not be concerned
that they were going to suddenly
be cross-examined and not believed to be
truthful and because what we're hearing
is that
coming forward with an allegation like
this is an extremely difficult process
and that the victims need to be treated
in the first instance like they are
telling the truth that doesn't mean that
somewhere in the process we wouldn't
discover otherwise but the design of
this is in that particular instance
leaning towards the more trauma-formed
approach but that is
that is a a decision for you all too so
so
so i would be more comfortable with
saying presumption of being truthful
with shall be treated with respect and
dignity because it seems to me like
that's what you're trying to achieve and
we don't want to
create a
legal argument where there doesn't need
to be one
is that
i think that's an excellent suggestion
thank you
i would suggest that the presumption
does need to be there you're talking
about such a power differential here
you're talking about people who were
incarcerated they were abused by guards
there were no witnesses
i could believe me any one of those
victims can probably tell you in great
detail today even if it's 20 or 30 years
later exactly what happened to them
because it never leaves your mind
and
i think that when you just make them try
to prove everything everything they say
they can't they can't because there's no
witnesses there's nothing there there
has to be some sort of recognition that
they're not making this out a whole
cloth and i think just like any witness
on the stand when you question them
after a while you get a sense as to
whether they're lying or they're telling
the truth and i think that it's going to
become apparent with these witnesses
when they come forward and with these
great detail of exactly what happened to
them that that you're going to know
whether they're making it up or whether
they're telling what they remember and
you know for some of these victims that
is the only way that if you understand
that you've got to presume it because
these guards were very clever they did
everything they could to make sure
there's no fingerprints
respectfully i couldn't disagree more i
i just think that this is you know this
is so we you know take it
you know we we should just we should
this just goes you know to take it on a
certain app we should presume that
whoever said justice kavanaugh you know
abused them that we should just presume
that what they said is true that's so
that's the way we should start it i i
just cannot accept that
representative
uh yes um
i think that
i i understand the argument on both
sides but the point is
that we will have
investigations of these allegations
it's not like
you know
whatever they say is automatically
going to go forward right i mean
we're investigating it
and so what i what i
think this says
is that if you come in
that we will
presume that you're telling the truth
and then through the investigation
process
we will determine whether or not you are
in fact telling the truth
and so this is this i think if i
understand it correctly
is simply to get the people through the
door
and then the investigation
will determine
whether or not
it's true or false just because it's
presumed doesn't mean that it's going to
move forward it just means that we will
accept your
allegations and go forward and that's
not a lawyer talk but that's
so
so neither of us are lawyers right
right
so so i i don't know if that's the
second part of what you said is is built
into this that whatever is said it will
be also subject to
the investigation
and and if and if if we get
into a hard position where where the
presumption of truthfulness is in there
you know i i would just ask for an
independent read to
to say that initially presumed perhaps
subject to
other
factors or qualifications but but but i
don't want some administrator to read
this and say hey i i have some serious
doubt here based on my life experience
and my ability to work with people where
i don't really believe everything i'm
hearing but it says in the law
i i have to presume truthfulness and and
put more weight on that statement than
i think i should so i see
you all have heard the conversation and
so you know i i'm not going to be
resolving it but i i just if you would
come back and address this specifically
because because i hear representative
walls i hear representative lynn and i i
just want to make sure that we're
you guys think through it
and we will do that thank you i i think
we will focus on trying to come up with
something that allows for the
um
the truth to be got at during the
process but also tries to incentivize
people to come in the front door as you
look we're we are uh we are almost done
so uh number 22 is actually a duplicate
of an earlier one i don't think we need
to to talk about it again and number 23
um is the
very small change in language at page
seven line 12
and it simply takes a a may to a shell
so that the administrator
will have a requirement to come back and
ask for the fund to be expanded if we
okay so um i think this has been great
so for the
committee members
it's easy for us to know what we just
talked about
but
what i'm going to ask you to do is to to
think about this in terms of is there
something that you still believe needs
to be discussed that weren't in the ag's
notes did we overlook something
you know not not because we want to just
but just because of the process
representative walsh
and then we'll go walner and emmerich
that's right i i do have one thing it
was actually what's in 23 but i also
want to ask before i get to that are we
going to hear from attorney
i'm never going to say this right
vincennes
i intend to thank you
sorry i will learn how to say his name
um
so
the lawyer in me locked this one caught
my eye previously and we have not
discussed it in this committee and it
says here that there's a requirement
that the administrator ask for
additional funds but i have been in this
legislature long enough to know that
just because somebody asks for the funds
doesn't mean they're going to get it
and
in a normal civil proceeding if you win
a judgment against the state there's a
number of ways to recover you're not
limited to a particular fund and i take
you back to a little bit of history to
when mel thompson was governor
and there was a fight with somebody that
went all the way to the supreme court
that about whether or not you could tape
over on your license plate something
that said live free or die and the state
lost it and the the
the plaintiffs wanted judgment against
the state and governor thompson refused
to pay the judgment so what ended up
happening was
the feds went into the liquor store and
said
open the cash register we're taking the
money and they immediately called the
governor and the governor said call the
treasurer whoever he called and said cut
the check
and the point being is that they had an
alternative way of getting the money
they weren't limited to a specific fund
set up by the legislature
and i'm concerned that future
legislators might choose not to
further fund a fund and i'm wondering if
there's a way that we should be putting
in here
to protect the victims here that they're
not dependent on the women of the
legislature to fund the fund but that
they have a way to recover from the
state even if the legislature doesn't
fund the fund if they have a valid
do you think you might have recommended
language around that or are you are we
going to do what we've been doing and
ask the ag to think about it and come
back to us
um i think it would be very easy to do
it there is a provision
i don't have it in front of me at the
moment but i did notice that there's
specific language in here talking about
the money coming from the fund i think
that language can be
easily amended so that you're not
limited to the fund so i think the ag i
think the plaintiff's lawyer i think
anybody could i mean
again i don't have it right in front of
me at the moment but i think it'd be
easy in language to amend that you're
not limited to the fund
i i i'm open to considering it i
it's hard for me to imagine
if we have valid claims against the
state the legislature not doing its job
and and appropriating the funds but
this is only my third term so you your
cynicism may be well received
deserved so
do do you all have any comment on this
discussion
yeah i i think my comment on that that
that is one of
on a number of these things we would say
ultimately it's a decision to be made by
you this is i think especially that type
of a decision but i still will comment
on it
i generally would recommend against an
open-ended appropriation i think
institutionally
um i
i think in the day and age we're living
in i i don't doubt that our legislature
would appropriate funds to pay claims
that have gone through a process that's
set up that that were that were validly
awarded so i guess my general comment is
legally i would never recommend to you
that you
have an open-ended appropriation and
second you know i think institutionally
it is better not to presume that the
legislature would not
um appropriate additional funds for
commitments that it made i think it's
better to presume that it would
appropriate additional funds for for
commitments that it makes so those are
my comments but we're happy to think
about this if you would like us to and
think about language and and thank you
for throwing the word presumption in
there a couple of times just to remind
us what the word means so
um
did you want to
say anything to that or shall we go to
represent walnut i'll just say real
quick we all know one legislature can't
bind a future legislature that's one of
those lessons you'll learn if you've
been around here more than one term and
that's where this concern comes from is
that what we're doing here we are not
binding future legislators and
legislatures or legislators so that's
why i'm thinking that
you know we should not be limiting it to
the fund that we are funding now
because we don't know how this if
there's some sort of the economy crashes
or something that the legislature is
going to go ah we don't feel like using
that money right now we're short money
all over the place and that's why i
don't want to presume that the
legislature will
given this unknown future decide that
they're going to fund this and i think
that these victims should have the same
rights as any
uh
buddy who has a claim against the state
thank you
i just have a couple of things that i
would like to hear a little bit more
about
one of them being
the
section
the into the administrator and the uh
choosing of the administrator
and that um
the
claimant's
counsel
would
oh i'm sorry that the claimant's counsel
would have input and
instead of
being
more involved at that point can you just
you mean that the claimant's counsel
would not be more involved or that the
attorney general would not be able to
the claimant's counsel would not be um
yeah the
i think
it is drafted currently in such a way
that um
both sides would have to agree
to the appointment of an administrator
or otherwise the claimant's counsel
would simply recommend to their clients
um okay thank you i
want to hear more about that
the other the other part that i can
continue
to think about is the physical abuse
and claims of people who were
physically abused
and not um
and not just sexually abused
have you given any consideration to that
we are we are continuing to think about
that we haven't made any modifications
in these recommendations to you
that you're not alone in that concern we
have not yet included recommendations
that this the scope of this be expanded
to include other types of claims because
we haven't yet
arrived at a at a way to do that
within the structure that exists in this
bill so
a claim of sexual abuse there's just no
circumstance in which that is okay and
so a presumption of truthfulness and a
way of vetting claims for a sexual abuse
claim um is is what this bill is
currently designed or our
recommendations to you are currently
designed with that approach in mind but
when you move into an arena where you
have claims of physical abuse or
emotional abuse those things can be
characterized that way but they can also
be characterized as activities that
happen in a detention facility someone
it is a physical environment it is an
emotionally difficult environment and so
the vetting for those types of claims
would would likely look different than
this process
and so we are continuing to think about
ways we might be able to include those
but we haven't yet arrived at a way that
we're ready to recommend to you thank
you so so
so i've thought about this issue about
how physical abuse fits into this since
the last meeting and knowing that this
was important to representative rogers
and and the way i've come to view it and
please tell me if this is a decent way
of looking at it
is that we're setting up a very specific
program for very specific purpose we
know that there's been sexual abuse we
know there's a lot of claims we want a
special process to take care of that and
within the claims process
if there's been physical abuse on top of
or in addition to the sexual abuse then
that that's an extenuating circumstance
and that can affect what the the payout
may be
but if it's purely
a physical abuse claim
we already have structures as i
understand it for
those claims to be filed in the ordinary
course of business
and so it isn't that we're saying that
we don't care about physical abuse only
we're just saying that that
is outside of the scope of this special
program
is that is that reasonable
yes it is i think the way this is
currently drafted it includes exactly
there was a
in one version of this we have many
versions
it said to the effect that the
cases or the
plaintiffs will be taken in the order in
which it's received
my only comment on that was to say if
it's complete
because it was quite a bit of verbage
about having a completed file so you got
to
modify we'll take them in the order
they're received
completed completed and
received you know what i'm trying to say
otherwise somebody gives you an imp
they're third in the door but it's they
give you 10 of the information they
start screaming you can't you can't
go to number four i'm number three
so i i do understand what you're saying
and if that's still unclear we'll we'll
work on that yeah i can't find it in the
representative umberger
yes this is easy
page
6 7
line 29
um it says that
the administrator
shall annually submit a report
um i would like to say that i would
anticipate
that the fiscal committee would like
this
as well
but would like it more than annually
and so
so
you know i would
i would suggest
that we at least go to quarterly
and i say that be just because of what
representative wallace was talking about
that we need to know when we are coming
close
to that
you know
100 million dollar figure
and it's not
you know
it'll it'll probably not get
other than cursorary looked at
until
you know
a year
or more
but we need to have the background for
that so if we could just
change that a little bit
we can include that do you have um
a concern if we start that a little bit
of the way into the process in the early
phase it's going to be all about design
right no no that's you know i don't care
when you know but okay i just i just
feel that we need to be able to track
what's going on
with the physical committee
thank you
so
so i agree with that quarterly issue and
and maybe in year five we can drop it to
some other rate but but certainly in the
initial phase um earlier we had talked
about a conversation having the matrix
reviewed by the joint legislative fiscal
committee of course i meant the
executive council too i didn't mean that
that standard process of of how we do
that is what i intended i didn't mean to
ignore the executive council and
governor
i'm not sure
that that should go to the executive
council
the matrix that's not that's not part of
their role is it yeah i i
i do i've seen other legislation where
something has to come back before the
fiscal committee to be approved um i
think this is the type of instance where
it wouldn't necessarily go to the
governor and council
i think that
you know
and i i i say this and i think the
governor would probably agree with me so
i don't want to get out in front of him
but even though he's a client you know
that would set up a a situation which
the governor alone when something has to
go to governor and council the governor
alone can
can can stop it right you know so you're
it's one person and the executive
council will not have been nearly as
familiar with all of these discussions i
mean this
and and what went into crafting the
legislation so it's typically a fiscal
committee and governor and council
process for
um
for for spending money and this is
spending money but
it's not as if each individual claim is
coming through to be approved it's just
the general guidelines and so i
it's ultimately up to you but i do think
this is a situation which if you didn't
include the governor and council i don't
think that would seem like uh
an unusual omission it would it would
actually seem unusual i think to submit
something like this to the governor and
council
i appreciate the education and the grace
that which you just both told me that
i'm wrong
it's okay i withdraw my comment
thank you
i had another thing that occurred to me
that we did not discuss yet today and
that is is the 1.5 million dollar cap
still in this legislation
so given the more recent
settlements and the more recent cases
that involve sexual abuse like the larry
nassar cases and the size of the
settlements and judgments in some of
these more recent cases
i i think we should revisit that and we
should be looking at a broader selection
of
you know what what are the recent um
settlements and those kinds of things
and i think that should be incorporated
into that and we should re-examine
whether 1.5 million really is the right
cap
before you answer i i i feel obligated
to let the people who have been waiting
patiently for
a house bill 103.
i i think we're going to have to
postpone the hearing on that i'm sorry
we've got several people that in the
brain trust here that require a 12 45
hard break
and uh and we still have a couple of
people to hear on this bill so so if
you're one of the patient ones uh you
thank you for that representative waltz
i think to that i would just say to keep
it short we're
i think we have been and we remain open
to
reviewing additional um data that might
in consideration of whether to to
increase that cap
we've done our own research and i i
still feel
pretty strongly that that 1.5 million is
an appropriate cap but we we have
invited
plaintiff's council to to provide us
with additional verdict research or
settlement research on that front we we
have yet to receive that to this state
but we're happy to to look at that if
that's provided but i think based on the
research we've done and we're certainly
open to reviewing other research we
remain confident that 1.5 million is the
representative
did did you have comments i i we had a
hallway conversation about the 1.5
million
cap i think it's what it should be for
the time being yes that's what you were
referring to that conversation all right
i just didn't want your comments left
out um
all right
so i don't know that we're going to
resolve that today um if if if you
wouldn't mind sticking around
we have um the plaintiff's attorney
the last name apparently is so hard to
pronounce that i'm just going to invite
you to come up because you know who you
are
and uh
and and i
i'm gonna i'm gonna give you like at
least five minutes to just riff and do
whatever you want
and then if you but i would like you
before you end i would like you to stick
your finger in specific parts of where
we are with 1677
and tell us if you are
if you have a disagreement that the
public should know about
uh and then represent shapiro hands up
so what i have to do for procedure is i
have to open the hearing on hb 103 and
then immediately i'll be putting us into
recess on it and i'll be scheduling it
for 10 a.m on the 24th of february
probably in this room
i'm sorry
i i i hope you were fascinated by this
great
uh all conversation would you would you
introduce yourself for the record and i
think you're going to have to spell your
last name i will again thank you or
thank you uh
representative edwards uh my name is
david
vissinanzo
n v-i-c-i-n-a n z o
and i am uh used to spelling it 10 15
times a day so
ever since i started working
it's actually phonetic but it's it's a
difficult when you look at it
i'm not going to be able to do quite
what you've invited me to do
representative edwards today i i can't
go through and
it would we don't have the time we don't
and i but i can tell you that we have
been doing that with
john framela and and with jennifer
ramsey
and we you know especially in the last
week have
had some very productive conversations
in my view
our court for the next draft and then we
are going to turn it around as quickly
as we can with a more comprehensive red
line we did do a red line
but it was so comprehensive that nobody
could follow it uh you were careful
lawyers and we got lots of ideas
probably too many
so i'm not able really today and i
understand that there will be another
opportunity in the future but i think
today is premature and it really will
take
longer than we have what i want to do
though is focus on
the three three core principles
that uh we believe and we think the
experts believe
are essential to a
productive and successful and effective
uh and fair
settlement process and it really boils
down to and we've talked to many experts
and i know
jennifer ramsey has as well and john
and we're learning and i've learned a
lot because i've done hundreds of these
mostly in the form of mediations
involving historical child sexual abuse
cases so i have a good feel for how they
work and i have a couple of
words at the end i'd really like to
address some things that justice lynn
said
i'm sorry justice lynn it's a force of
habit i'm not sure i'm ever going to
lose that habit
um but the three core principles that
the experts agree
are essential to a fair and a
fair process that can be
fairly described as victim-friendly and
trauma informed
first of all
including all the child victims in the
process
i know that there are ways you can divvy
them up and you can
segregate half or more of them and say
no you're not invited you can do that i
know there are legal distinctions and
there are technical distinctions
but
what victims hear is that
my trauma
is not as important as other people's
trauma
my trauma that has so severely affected
my life is given a lesser priority and
no matter no matter no matter all the
words we might say to try to mitigate
that and explain why well there are
legal differences and so forth they're
not they're not going to hear that and
frankly i don't want to be the one i
will not be the one to deliver that
message to them i'm not going to say
that i am in favor
of discriminating against some victims
in favor of other victims i just don't
think that it's a good idea and i think
it's a bad thing for the state to do
i don't think the state wants that
perception
yes sir
i just want to track along with what
you're saying
because what i what i think i'm hearing
is
in processing is that
the ag from my perspective and and
attorney ramsey have have done
a good job they're not done yet but
they've they've done a good job of
making sure that the the trauma-informed
respect is included in this
and and i'm hearing though that you may
not accept that that's true and and we
have language for you to look at for
that and then as you're talking about
respecting all victims
i i
again my perception is that we're doing
that
uh and if you don't
i just need you to be really clear
like i i need to know your position on
for example
um the uh the physical abuse
being a carve out and being left to the
standard i'm very happy to do that all
right all right first i want to and i
hate to interrupt sort of your you know
overview because i know that's i
appreciate it it's a good way to kind of
cut to the chase and actually
clarify the message but thank you i
wanted to say i i absolutely do agree
that john
and jen ramsey are trying very hard to
make it a trauma informed process i
believe that but for all of us it's an
education this is not an area that we're
all born knowing
for me it was a very much an education
20 years ago when i was thrown into the
middle of the church crisis
and i've been one way or another been
involved ever since generally
you might say the defense side but i've
never viewed it as plain of defense i've
viewed it more as a collaborative
process to achieve justice and fairness
for everybody involved and hopefully
some measure of reconciliation between
people who are tremendously harmed and
the institutions that did the harm but
it's a process we have to learn
um i i do i've been speaking to
one of the uh preeminent experts on
child especially adolescent trauma his
name is david finkelhor and he is right
here at unh
been doing this for 50 years since he
got his p 45 years since he
got his phd at harvard and is
very much a national nationally
recognized expert on the subject what
he's told me is that his research
indicates
that as bad as sexual trauma is for an
adolescent
violent trauma is worse
and even worse than sexual and violent
trauma is emotional trauma and he says
it seems kind of counterintuitive but
it's true
and of course in our case here the
emotional trauma there's a lot of
emotional trauma usually it's attached
to physical or sexual occasionally it
happens without the physical without the
sexual and that would be the instance in
which
kids were confined
a month at a time
sometimes two three four months at a
time in a cell without a human contact
that's the worst kind of trauma but
that's being excluded from this bill
i i know that it's that's it's a it's
maybe a little tougher to um
to wrestle with because it's not such a
bright line the way sexual abuse is
everybody knows sexual abuse is off
limits and yes there may be times when
certain amounts of confinement might be
appropriate and it might depend whether
it's the 70s or the 80s or 90s in which
our understanding of of what was
appropriate for adolescents was at the
time or what the policies were but we
could wrestle through that in this
process there's no reason that the right
administrator with the right guidance
can't handle all the victims and i think
the state has a tremendous incentive to
do it first we don't want to
discriminate
child victims are child victims they all
suffered and they're still suffering
today
um and the other incentive is
they're they're filing lawsuits too and
do we want to get do we want to get a
process that's going to work here that's
going to be attractive to the victims
and and successful so that in a year
from now we can say that we've done the
right thing and we're starting to put
this in the rear view mirror or do we
want to allow the litigation to clog our
courts for the next two three four years
and a constant stream
of news reports about you know
what the allegations are and what the
latest thing in the litigation is
i i don't think the state wants that i
really think the state has a tremendous
opportunity here to actually deal with
this in a in a victim-centered and uh
fair way that accounts for all the human
suffering that unfortunately was
inflicted or at least allowed to be
inflicted may i interact with you on
this yes okay um
are are you are you telling us
that
if there were
a juvenile that had been subjected to
[Music]
unreasonable solitary confinement over a
prolonged period of time yes that that
individual
today and in the past
has had
no
or inadequate access to
having their case uh receive justice are
you are they are they excluded from the
today's process and current process
uh
well they're they're excluded from this
bill
is that what you meant yes no no i mean
we have a a system where people can
apply and
and go through a settlement process with
the ag and and i just want to make sure
that in the earlier uh discussion i had
i think it was rep attorney ramsey who
confirmed my understanding is that
uh the physical abuse is an extenuating
circumstance within this bill
but that cases that are strictly
physical abuse
would
remain the province of the standard
procedures and so as i'm listening to
your
your testimony and i'm sorry to
interrupt but we're starting to run out
of time
is
i just want to make sure
that
we aren't
leaving here thinking
that those who kids who have been
physically abused or or unreasonably
incarcerated in solitary confinement
i don't want to
know i i don't i just don't want it to
be the case that we don't have
a process set up now already for them to
go through well the only process i'm
aware of is the judicial system
that that's that's all that exists and
that a lot of these cases do involve
uh those are emotional uh distress
emotional uh torture
confinement physical abuse okay broken
ribs so your
your position is that that's inadequate
it's there but it's inadequate and we
need to roll it into this uh this
special bill i i well i like the word
inadequate yeah i what i what i would
say is
phrasing more positively is this is a
great opportunity to take care of all of
those in an expedited fashion there is
there is a way to bake into the matrix
and into the process of the
administrator that you can account for
the differences between sexual assault
and physical assault and illegal
confinement and so forth
all the arguments will be made by the
attorney general's office there may be
mitigating or extenuating circumstances
in some of those cases but that can all
be baked into the process and you it's
so important that we get an
administrator
who is wise and very familiar with new
hampshire law has a lot of experience
with this and is trusted by everybody
and that's the kind of person that will
say
well i i hear what you're saying
uh that you were confined for three
months and you did you and you couldn't
con you couldn't even talk to your
parents and
and you didn't talk to anybody
i didn't mean to like lead your
testimony too much okay but i i re we
really have a hard stop at 12 45 and and
your conversation with us
has clarified the issue that we need to
think about we think so
encompass everybody we don't want to
discriminate against any of the victims
yes sir i respect that opinion and we're
continuing that conversation with the ag
you mentioned there were three things
and i think you just did one i did one
and the second one is somewhat related
and that is that we are uh very very um
it's very important to us that the
administrator be
truly independent
and
we've consulted with numerous national
experts who say that's standard you you
would never appoint cardinal law to
administer the boston archdiocese
claim settlement process because nobody
would use it nobody would trust it and
certainly it has to be can't be the ag
that is going to be
settling claims with victims who think
that the state is what or know that the
state is is the source of the harm and
that john is the representative of the
state it just doesn't work i i it has to
be separated from the ag
and i think very simple tweak in the
bill would be
that the attorney general and the clan
the cl and the victims would agree
on who the administrator was because who
it is is going to be very very important
as i said somebody truly independent
somebody viewed as wise fair prudent and
very experienced and who's probably had
a lot of experience at discerning
what's nonsense and what's not you know
what's fair and what's not so so if i
may i i want to continue to sharpen the
edge here yes um
so
um honest on a separation argument
within the state
we have a separation of time
because we're going back to
it had been 1980 now it's just at any
time so there's a separation of time
there's also a separation of department
the the the ag's office is fundamentally
different than the ydc in terms of their
mission and their personnel yes and so
so one could argue that there is
separation but i think you're saying it
that it's inadequate
i am it's it's inadequate i do
understand the separation and and so
forth but
my clients don't
they see it as all one state and they
think well that's the lawyer for the
state uh isn't he obliged to get the
best deal for the state in every case
that's a good question i think he is
under the rules of professional conduct
and
if it's not separated from him they're
not going to trust the result so they
won't participate so so i want to let
you know i know that i'm not being fair
to you and so the next time we come up
you're you're going to go first we're
going to hear 103 and then you're going
to go first okay so i want that and and
and and will fully respect your time i
i'm just pounding towards the 12 45 and
you've got .3.3 is we don't want to
strip the victims of choices unduly and
what this bill still does is say that
you have to waive your judicial rights
as a price of admission to this process
and we don't want to do that you do so
you you're not going to get people to do
that who will say all right i give them
my right to sue
now i enter the process i have no no
idea first i'm not even sure the
administrator is independent second i
have no idea what if i what the award
will be
or if even if i'll get an award and
you're asking me to waive my only
leverage before i enter the process
that's not going to work they're not
going to do that and they shouldn't be
forced to do that they should be
required to waive it once they are aware
of the ward and they decide to take it
and issue a release to the state for all
claims
so as long as i'm on record of being
unfair to you i i'd like to take like 30
seconds of your remaining time and give
it to the attorney general either to him
or
attorney ramsey to just respond come up
to the and respond
to the issue
that is being presented that we are
in this bill
denying
standard judicial rights expected
judicial rights whatever the right term
is
so the way jennifer ramsey for the
record for the the way that this bill is
is structured and the current
recommendations to you still include
that the
claimant would need to select into the
process and would waive the right to
continue to pursue litigation
in order to choose to participate
instead in this alternative resolution
process and that that would happen at
the beginning the participation in the
process is entirely voluntary so if a
victim wishes to pursue litigation
instead of this process
that is still an option for them
and it's my understanding that opting um
for acceptance of the process and not
additional litigation that that's kind
of normal in an arbitration environment
is or is that just a bad analogy no
that's a good analogy and and in fact we
have included some references to the
arbitration statute for that reason um
it is important not for this process to
just be
um a waste of state resources
for a claimant to go through it get to
the end decide they don't like the
result and then proceed on with
litigation
all right thank you so
please uh continue and
[Music]
there may be a number of ways to address
it what we want to make sure is that
our claimants are putting their best
foot forward and not waiving what
may be their only chance it's some kind
of recompense for the suffering they've
endured
um it's a big risk for them to enter a
process about which they have no idea
what the result will be
maybe if as we develop the matrix maybe
as we have more security about who the
administrator is and whether or not
they're going to have a level of trust
in the administrator and in the matrix
and the process perhaps we could talk
more about that and we we will continue
talking more can i have one more point
before i i quit i want to address uh
justice lynn of course had many
many very cogent comments but there was
one in particular and i think everybody
here would would probably
take some comfort in knowing it
it goes back to cooperation with the
criminal case
i of course
applaud what the attorney general is
doing with the criminal investigation
it's long overdue i will say that the
reason the criminal investigation began
is because my co-counsel russ riley
brought his first client david meehan in
to meet with gordon mcdonald
before anything else happened and said
gordon
that
my guy is credible and truthful and he's
telling you that terrible things happen
at ydc and it was widespread and there
were a lot of people involved and a lot
of victims not just him so what we have
done ever since then and of course
gordon to his credit took it and ran
with it gordon of obviously someone i
have tremendous respect for my partner
for 17 years tremendous guy with
tremendous integrity and i
i think he's done state a great service
by by opening this up for public viewing
and ensuring that it will never happen
again
so much to learn here but what we have
done ever since and we have 500 clients
now we have asked each one of our
clients after we do the initial
interview with them
and find out what happened we asked them
all to go to the state police and be
interviewed by the state police and we
don't require them we don't make them
because we want victims to have options
not a single one has refused us
every one of our clients has been
interviewed by the state police now we
don't have access to those interviews
because the criminal and the civil
processes are totally separate and jen
ramsey doesn't have access to those
interviews nobody does right now but i
want you to know that that's part of our
vetting process and
and it and and it's also a testament to
how much we support the state's efforts
in that criminal investigation every one
of our folks has been interviewed by the
state police and also offers a layer of
extra protection because of course if
you're not candid with the state police
there are all kinds of legal
consequences so you better be right and
you better be telling the truth
and we tell them all that and they
they know what the risks are and not a
single one of us has refused us they've
all been interviewed by the state police
i'll leave it with that
so let let me ask you a question um
we we would like to continue this
conversation on the 24th of february
uh we'll probably start this hearing at
like 10 45 at 11 o'clock that we're
going to hear 103 first
um and and you'll you'll lead off
what what uh what i'm going to ask you
is is that enough time for you to think
that you and the ag office can get to
the point where
you
we don't need to talk about the things
that you agree to agree on but the
things where you have not come into
agreement
we we really could use a very precise
sharp
to the point description of
that position versus this position so
that so that we know what sort of issue
that we need to decide on yes i
appreciate that and that date would be
fine school vacation is the next week
and i'm hoping to be in florida with my
three youngest so the timing's good for
me too i'm hoping to go with you
uh so is it and that timeline is okay
okay so
uh with that is there anyone else in the
room that
had something they wanted to say today
and has not
is there anyone on the panel that still
has something to say that they have not
okay so with that um i'm gonna thank you
for your time thank you and uh and i
hope you accept my apology for cutting
you short no problem um but we're gonna
close the hearing on hb one six seven
seven
and with that i'm going to open
the hearing on hb 103 and we're going to
go into recess on hb 103 until 24
february at 10 a.m in this room meetings
closed
yeah
i i did not think it was going to take
this but i i having done it i think it
needed to be
so so pat i just realized what we did
not do
we did not
take
kathy rogers comments
you